welcome to CBS this morning from
Washington DC the new normal in America
is keeping clear of the coronavirus from
business to sports to family life the
list of schools and activities forced to
close in order to protect public health
jumped dramatically yesterday companies
have asked millions of employees to work
from home to protect their colleagues
the Dow Jones Industrial Average
plummeted 10 percent yesterday its worst
day in more than 32 years and the
government still faces serious questions
over the limited level of coronavirus
testing CBS News is tracking the extent
of testing in every state in this
country the numbers show that just over
13 thousand Americans have been tested
and more than 1,700 of them have tested
positive for coronavirus the growing
number of empty store shelves is a sign
that we could be in for a long siege
from this virus dr. Anthony Fauci head
of the National Institute of Allergy and
Infectious Diseases at the National
Institutes of Health told a
congressional committee yesterday that
the testing system in the u.s. is quote
failing he joins us now from Washington
dr. pouchy good morning I want to begin
with family doctors because they're on
the front lines of this fight against
the virus and I want to play a part of
an interview we did yesterday with a
family doctor in New Jersey discussing
his frustrations with testing and then
get your message to him they want the
doctors to start testing them in their
own practices rather than sending
everybody to the ER to get tested but
they don't realize that we don't have
the kits yet it's really very
frustrating because we can't diagnose
these people we can tell everybody to
self isolate but people tend to not
always listen to what we tell them and
if we have people slipping through the
cracks they have the potential to in
fact many others before we finally catch
up to them to test them and that in a
nutshell is how this spreads doctor felt
you what's your message to doctors like
that one well obviously that's a very
frustrating situation as I mentioned
that the hearing yesterday the original
system that was set up worked for a
particular type of a public health
response patient physician
relationship order a test etc it was not
designed for a much broader blanketing
of the country to have tests available
that is being rapidly corrected
admittedly back when this particular
individual had that experience it did
not work for that particular physician
but I'm looking forward now we had a
taskforce meeting yesterday and we heard
that the kinds of tests from the
commercial sector that would be
available readily available is really
very very close right now
very close doctor voucher you said
there'd be four million tests sent out
by the end of this week are we on track
for that you know there's a difference
between a test being sent out and the
connection between the test and those
who could actually administer the test
what we really need is to get the test
available in venues that people could
easily access that has not been the case
but as I mentioned just a moment ago
looking forward it is very likely we
will have that within the next week or
so
dr. Falchi the FDA just issued an
emergency authorization for a test that
can be administered and in about three
and a half hours where you get the
results back how how soon will folks be
able to get those tests and who will be
tested well the situation is that the
test you're referring to is it really
what I was what I was just mentioning a
moment ago something that would be
available that is not just going through
a multiple step process the person comes
in right now or at least in the next few
days to a week and it has a symptom that
is suggestive of coronavirus back a week
or two or three ago there were
restrictions on that those restrictions
have been lifted by the FDA one of the
restrictions were you had to have proven
contact with someone who either has
corona virus was suspected of corona
virus that's off the board now if you go
in there's a good reason for you to get
it you're gonna get a test but again
it's gonna be graded it's not gonna all
happen tomorrow the next day it's gonna
start going like this that relatively
soon that kind of issue that was just
mentioned
by the person who spoke hopefully will
no longer be existent now they're gonna
be questions about what took so long but
for now I want to talk about the bigger
picture how this testing when it comes
online fits into a broader response
China has been praised for cutting the
number of new cases in part by not
having home quarantine or self
quarantine anyone who test positive is
separated out from the population do we
need more draconian measures like that
in this country even though we're a very
different population you know you could
do what we call mitigation right now
without necessarily having widespread
testing we certainly do want a lot more
testing than we have right now but you
have to separate the distance the
difference between testing and not the
kinds of things you're hearing about
what we call social distancing which
means staying away from crowds doing
teleworking where appropriate now where
appropriate closing schools the
canceling events that bring many many
people together you can do that right
now and it's being done right now
without having testing obviously we want
to and we'll have considerably more
testing in the future but you don't wait
for testing to do the mitigation you
could do it right now
dr. Falchi we've seen Swift and
unnerving changes to everyday American
life you've been in this position for 35
years or more can you say this is the
most severe disruption to everyday
living in this country in your lifetime
yes of course I mean there have been an
awful lot of challenges over the 36
years that I've been doing this I mean
obviously hiv/aids that was a disruption
for a beginning a very selected
demographic group in the country even
though there was a lot of general fear
but with regard to disruption of
everyday life we have not seen that
before but we've not had this kind of a
situation before I mean we've had
pandemics the 2009 h1n1 swine flu was a
pandemic but you know it was influenza
we were simply were familiar with what
influenza does familiar whether it's
seasonal capability right now there are
a lot of unknowns and I think that's the
thing that frightening people and those
you're absolutely right those
nones are the scary part of all this dr.
Anthony kouchi we thank you